joining us now with reaction South
Carolina Senator Lindsey Graham senator
with all due respect you rightly said if
there's no due process it's dead on
arrival in the Senate I would think the
Senate led by Republicans is not going
to put their seal of approval on
something as corrupt as this I think
would be a danger to the presidency in
the future for us to legitimize what's
going on in the house there's no civil
proceeding in America no criminal
proceeding in America that denies a
person to tell their side of the story
by calling witnesses except in the house
and every American deserves the right to
convert their accuser that's not being
done in this case so I don't want to
legitimize this Costas a threat to the
presidency then there's the allegation
the allegation is that Donald J Trump
withheld aid to the u train unless the
Ukrainian government investigated Joe
Biden and hunter Biden for corruption
the problem with that allegation is this
not true the aid was delivered to the
Ukrainian government and there was no
investigation of hunter Biden or Joe
Biden how long does it take to dispose
of that let me ask you because again the
due process you were part of impeachment
in 1998
this is not your first rodeo senator
you're aging yourself I was on the air -
okay guilty but every consideration
those given Bill Clinton Bill Clinton's
lawyers the minority party are all
denied here because at the end of the
paragraph it all says the same thing it
goes yeah at the discretion of the
chairman he said he wanted the
whistleblower Republicans gave a list
they said no to every Republican witness
and now they're cherry-picking the two
witnesses that they think will be most
favorable to them and ignoring all the
ones that destroyed their narrative who
in the Senate what committee in the
Senate could call witnesses and
investigate hunter and Joe because I
identified the laws that I believe Joe
Biden broke well the allegation against
hunter Biden is that they had a conflict
of interest by serving on the board and
that Joe Biden weighed in to have the
prosecutor fired because he's getting
close to his son their State Department
Act
tivity talking about the conflict of
interest and there is a reasonable
investigation to be done here the
Foreign Relations Committee has
jurisdiction over the State Department
but let me get back to the point you
just made what's happening in the house
is basically unamerican
no American including Donald Trump
should be accused of misdeeds without
confronting their accuser which is the
whistleblower and no American should be
denied the ability to tell their side of
the story by calling witnesses to
explain their defense that's being
denied the president states to every
American who's going to watch tomorrow
this could not happen in your case this
couldn't happen in a parking ticket case
this couldn't happen in any civil matter
in America because due process requires
the ability of every American to call
witnesses on their behalf except for
President Trump so why am I not gonna
watch this hearing tomorrow because I
think it is a threat to the presidency I
don't want to legitimize it
it's unamerican it denies the basics of
due process who why won't the Senate now
they have the ability to investigate we
listen Joe Biden is bragging on tape
about giving you either fire this
prosecutor in six hours if you fire them
I'll give you a billion taxpayer dollars
you don't fire the prosecutor that's
investigating my zero experience son
who's being paid millions I'm taking the
money back with me now that to me looks
like a crime so why isn't the Senate now
that we know that that all happened
investigating for example who would you
like to be called in as witnesses and
what Committee in the Senate could call
them in well the Foreign Relations
Committee has jurisdiction over foreign
aid the State Department we're talking
about Joe Biden said you're not gonna
get a penny unless you fire the
prosecutor here's the question after
John Solomon's Ford a request is there a
reasonable belief that Joe Biden
intervene not because the prosecutor was
corrupt because he's getting close to
his son the paper trail suggests there
is a reasonable belief or at least
something to look at here so I'm hoping
that chairman rich will look into
whether or not
there was a conflict of interests
identified by the State Department
regarding hunter Biden being on this gas
board and whether or not Joe Biden
intervened after the raid can we can the
Senate call in the hearsay whistleblower
and put that person under old should the
Senate also call in Adam Schiff Adam
shifts staff for whatever contact they
had and should they call in Joe and
hunter Biden and why isn't this
happening simultaneously so the American
people can see both sides of of this and
see where the real corruption lies the
whistleblower is under the jurisdiction
of the Intel committee all things about
Hunter Biden are in the jurisdiction
Foreign Relations Committee and if our
Chairman rich I would call the State
Department officials in who expressed
concerns about a conflict of interest to
a hunter bite and see where that takes
you can you maybe talk to your
colleagues in the Senate and make that
happen
well the met the first thing I want my
colleagues is Senate to do is step up
and say what's going on the house is
unfair unamerican we're not going to
bless it and I'd like my colleagues in
the Senate to say there is no quid pro
quo here because the the money was given
to the Ukraine and a hunter body and Joe
Biden were not investigated I like
Republicans to speak up and say this is
a bunch of garbage and by the way the
president has a duty to faithfully
execute the laws on both issues there
were laws that were broken and they
never mentioned any aid money today
not one inning not one penny and that
guy's money the circus is coming to town
buckle up Thank You senator well we